r
はっはっは
noooooo
みなさんこんにちは
僕は犬飼宏と言います
コンピューターゲームの開発を20年
くらいやっています
で僕はですねコンピュータゲームの開発を
やっている仕事の名前のゲーム監督名乗っ
ています博士って書いてありますけどひろ
しって言うんです
うん
おじいちゃんふざけてたんだと僕は思って
ますけどね
でも子供の頃からずっとゲームが大好きで
あの今もずっとゲームを研究しています
でこうやってね専門家をやっているとあの
お父さんお母さんが子供のゲームやって
いる姿を見て心配してこういう質問しくん
ですねあのお子さんがゲームばかりしてい
てとても心配ですという話をしてくるん
ですね
そうそうですか
そうでもないでもよく聞くんですね
でここでいうゲームっていうのは一体どう
いうことを言ってるんでしょうかちょっと
いうか整理してみたいと思います
本屋さんに行くと実はゲームのことって
いうのは3カ所ぐらいに分かれて整理され
て置いてあるんですね
一つ目が
夫人の雑誌なんかのちょうどクラッカーと
かな近くにあるんですけれども
家庭とか教育とかスポーツとかというよう
な朝夕の店がありましてそこにゲームとが
ありますねお子さんと遊ぶようなゲームの
ほうがありますそれからコンピューターの
コーナーにはコンピューターゲームの本が
あります
そしてもう一つ
ビジネスの世界ではゲーム理論っていうな
ものを応用した仕事の本がたくさん置いて
あります
でこれはほん本屋さんの話なんですけれど
も実はもっともっと実はゲームてが
たくさんあって生活のいたるところにあり
ます
例えば
今日皆さん何人も来た
今日早かったよね
王子
ほんと
5時に起きたあ
30本したそれお父さんとお母さんに
終わったのかな
ほんと6時に起きた
それもねなんかみんなでを着ようって決め
て起きるわけじゃないそれから例えば歯を
磨こうねって言われたら本楽そういうこと
を
ルーそういうルールを決めてクリアして
いくということも実は広い意味ではゲーム
のことなんです
でゲームというのはとっても幅が広くて
とってもあのいつも生活に密着している
ことなんですねじゃあちょっともう一度
この先ほどの
ゲームばかりしていて心配です遊んで心配
ですっていうことの件これはねじゃあ一体
何も心配なのか
おそらく
コンピューターゲーム
っていうものが心配なんだと思います
これコンピューターゲームって
あの子供たちは普通にゲーム何の区別も
なく夢中になってゲームあらゆるゲームを
夢中になってプレイするだけなんですけど
も大人はコンピューターゲームということ
に心配するんですね
じゃあなぜ
コンピューターゲームというのを
心配なのかっていうとその人っていうのは
この写真の中にあります
コンピューター
子どもたちというのは遊んでいます
でコンピュータというのはゲームをやって
いる間ゴールを示してくれて失敗したら
優しく教えてくれてそれからもし成功し
たら役やったねって褒めてくれるレベル
アップとかって言うよね褒め上手なんです
ねコンピューターっていうのはとっても
遊び相手として優れてるんです
でこの姿こそが実はお父さんお母さんが
心配する元になっているんですね子ども
たちというのはコンピューターと子供達
だけで遊んでいて実はそのゲームというの
かやの底にお父さんとお母さんが入って
ゲームというのは一緒に参加しないと
分からないことが多いんですけども
お父さんとお母さんの外にいてゲームが
わからないのでやっぱり心配になってくる
それは当然のことだと思います
でもう1つの理由はこのコンピューター
ゲームの歴史というのがとても浅いことに
原因があると思います
人類が広域的てコンピューターとが登場し
たからまだまだ時間が短いですねここまで
40年ぐらいです
でこの歴史が浅いということでこれが本当
に良いものか悪いものか分からなくて不安
になるということがあります
だけども野球にも実はえーっ
歴史が浅い時期がありました
日本に野球が入っていたの1871年
あたりなんですけれどもこの時に大学生が
夢中になって野球えっている姿を見て新聞
に投稿します
学生たちが野球をやっていてボールを
グラブに向けるとその振動が脳に伝わって
勉強が出来なくなるから野球はやめた方が
いいってことが新聞に載ったんですねこれ
でそんぐらい野球ての心配されたものです
これ今でこそ笑い話なんですけどもどっち
大人たちは大真面目ですよ
まあ科学も発達してなかったのでそこまで
じゃなかったんですけどもこういう歴史が
浅いということがやっぱりコンピュータへ
の理解がまだ浅いということにあの
つながっています
もうちょっとですねゲームの歴史というの
をもうちょっとシェアを広げて見てみ
ましょう人類の最初にまで遡ります
人類の最初こういったね moda 猿
みたいな時こういう時は狩猟採集の社会と
言いますまだ木の実を取ったり狩りをし
たりする生活ですこの時に兄弟同士で
寝込んでいたんだじゃあ行ったりとか
するっていうことがレスリングの始まり
です殺さない程度に相手と一緒に取っ組み
合ったりするそれから号と痒みとかを
見つけてきてそれで遊び始める弓道だっ
たり剣道の始まりですねそれから時代が
進みます
時代は進んで農耕社会というの始まります
人々は村を作り始めてそこで年に1回収穫
をしてお祭りを始めますそのお祭りの時に
牛の暴行などを膨らまして
高村の間を行き来してパッ4ダウンしたら
来年はどっちかが豊作だって言うような事
っていうのが行われますそれがじゃあ
サッカー近です
集団ゲームの誕生ですね
それから
次の時代に行きます次の時代は
こういうクルマとか蒸気機関車でができ
ます産業革命が起きてこういう車が
どんどんどんどん発達してきて人々はこの
車で遊び始めますこの遊び始めた車で遊び
始めることをモータースポーツの代々木
始めます人々がどんどんどんどん買って
遊んでるんですねそして今僕たちが住んで
いる社会は it 革命の後の情報社会に
来ています
情報社会の道具といえばコンピュータです
この道具というのが遊びというのがこの
どこで遊んでるのがコンピューターゲーム
になるんですね
でこの角から読み取れることというのは実
はこういうことが出てきます
各時代で発明された新しい道具で人間と
いうのはずっと遊んできたんだということ
ですね
それからもう一つ
プレイヤーが遊びながら
プレイヤー自身が作ってきたという歴史た
んですね誰かが作ったというものではない
んですプレイヤー自身が遊びながら作って
きた歴史というのが人間のこのゲームの
歴史そのものになるんですね
サッカーというのも実はそうで
サッカーも長い歴史をかけて今のルールと
いうのが出来上がっています最初からこの
形であったわけではありません
誰かがサッカーをつくりましたと一緒に僕
はあったことはありません人類がずっと
長い間かけてサッカーというのプレイヤー
たちがその都度その都度変えて作ってきた
んですね
そうした歴史を考えるとやはりですねゲー
ムっていうのをコンピューターゲームと
いうのも実はこれからみんなで一生懸命
やって遊んで作ってお父さんお母さんも
一緒に入ってずっと作っていくって言う
必要があると僕は考えています
どんどんどんどんやってどんどんどんどん
評価をして
これからも歴史につなげていく必要が僕は
あると思います
そしてへとこれ最新のね僕が行っている
取り組みですぼくも一応トナーとしてこう
いう取り組みがあっていますちょっと
ムービー見てみましょう
言動たいというのを作ろうと思ってバブル
サッカーって言ってテレビで見た人もいる
かもしれないんですけどこれ俺運動会に
持ってるから面白いんじゃないかなと思っ
ていてこういうそれからライトドッティ
これは寝ないとで観客たちがプレイヤー
たちに体力を与えたり攻撃力をつけたりと
かするというコンピューターゲームと
ドッチボールを合体させたようなあの左か
リアルメーターのかあのヒットポイント
ブーブーでこれはねジャンプしてジャンプ
瞬間にビヨーンという写真が撮れるって
新しいトランっ
これはねちっちゃいヘリコプター ar
droneんですけどこれで新しい遊びで
は作れないかなと思ったんですこの運動会
ハッカソンっていうのはこうやって
どんどんどんどん新しいゲームを作って
いくその場でどんどんどんどん作って
どんどんどんどん改良して遊んでいく
そして新しいゲームを作っていくっていう
もんですこれなんかはインターネット越し
で立体の高ヘッドまずディスプレイとの
てってやる手にしですね
これは携帯のゲームという残しに裏し後ろ
につけて開けてあるカフェスマートフォン
ですねそれの色を当てるって言うあの
鬼ごっこ新しいを抜きます
こんなことでどんどん作って言ってるのが
この運動会ハッカソンという僕のやって
くると良いです
はっでこのどんどんどんどん一緒に作って
遊んでいくっていう行為を作る行為と遊ぶ
行為っていうのを分けてやっているわけで
はなく同時に行われていくってことが実は
重要だと思っていまして
開発するという
デベロップトそれから
プレイヤー
デベロップしながらプレーすることという
のに新しい言葉をこれ合成して作りました
それが
デベロップリアっていう言葉です面白いで
ベロプレイヤーみんなはねデベロップし
ながら作るプレイヤーだっていうその両方
を同時にやってる人たちなんですね誰かが
プレイヤーで誰かが作るってわけじゃない
んです
例えばね人間ってのは宇宙聖書の中でもね
遊んじゃってるんですよこんな風にして
サッカーボールがあってどこに行っても
遊ぶんですね
これから君たちも宇宙旅行するような時代
が来ると思いますその時に宇宙の中では
どんなゲームを君たちは作るんでしょうか
どんなゲームが遊ぶんでしょうか
何か思いつくからん
考えようね
で
この今ゲームの話をしていたら人類の最初
から宇宙の話まで広がってしまいました
さらに僕たちは長い長い時間をとび越え
なければいけません次の世代次の世代君
たちのが大人になって君たちが子供ができ
て君たちの魔王とかが生まれてくるじい
ちゃんおばあちゃんになって空想いう時に
ずっと残さなきゃいけないんですねその
ときに僕たちはどういう心構えをもったら
いいんだろうかということもすごく大事に
なってくるとを思います
それが実はスポーツマンシップという言葉
で人間っていうのは
悪い事しませんよとか迷惑かけませんよと
いうことを誓ってきた歴史がありますそう
いう良い発明もゲームの駅舎中にあります
でさっきの運動会ハッカソンの中にでベロ
プレイヤーたちがする選手宣誓というのを
最初に行って初めています選手っていうの
は聞いたことあるんだ
選手宣誓レベルプレイヤーん戦車先生
アーブあるんだえらいねぇ
それをねちょっと見てみましょうか
これ
やってみるこれ
じゃあやるかやるかじゃあちょっと経って
やっと立っ
じゃあ僕が1行ずつ読んでから
お父さんお母さんも経てばと一緒に一緒に
会いましょう
あの僕が1行ずつ選んだから続けていって
くださいね
いきましょう先生
我々レベロプレイヤー一同は
ペースマンシップに乗っ取
遊び作りシェアすることを誓います
yeah ありがとうございます
じゃあみんなでこれから楽しいゲームそれ
から長い歴史を作っていきましょう
ありがとうございました